[Applauso]
Permettetemi di tenere qualche appunto
perché
pensavo di sapere tutto ma il discorso
di Marco era così interessante che ho
paura che ho perso la concentrazione
grazie a Marco
la nostra non ho deve andare in loop le
mie diapositive
qualche secondo ripetutamente
comunque vedrete la nostra prima
scossone alla città è successo nel 2014
quando Venezia si è trovata con degli
enormi drappi lungo tutto il Canal
Grande con scritto con la dichiarazione
Venezia è Laguna con questa affermazione
volevamo ricordare tutti che il futuro
della Il destino della città e
inscindibile dal futuro della salute
della laguna che la circonda
oggi faccio un ulteriore passo avanti
per dire che i limiti di Venezia
rispecchiano i limiti
degli umani sulla sul mondo nel mondo e
questo può essere una cosa un po'
esagerato ma voglio veramente spiegare
come il nostro destino e interconnessa
con il destino dell'umanità
in
termini razionali e scientifici perché
dobbiamo rivitalizzare questa laguna qua
per massimizzare le funzionalità
ecologica e fisica per mitigare i
cambiamenti climatici in corso per
ottimizzare il capitale naturale che c'è
qui nella Laguna e anche serve per
attenuare i livelli d'acqua che
affliggono Venezia
uso un concetto molto
pragmatico e lo stesso concetto
sviluppato dall'economisti delle Nazioni
Unite che sono i servizi ecosistemici
questi sono quei beni e servizi che
abbiamo dall'ambiente che servono per la
società
hanno un valore esplicito che più o meno
facile da calcolare e non vuol dire che
dare un valore economico e di assoluta
importanza Ma certamente aiuta i
decisori politici a indirizzare le loro
scelte e Idem con lei investimenti ci
sono quattro tipi di servizio
ecosistemico ci sono quelli di
approvvigionamento che può essere per
esempio il reddito annuale dei Pescatori
di Burano che vivono della pesca ci
dietro quelli culturali che può essere
il giro di affari attorno alle regate
che ci sono in laguna e tutto il turismo
a questo associato ci sono i servizi
ecosistemici di supporto che sono le
cose dell'ambiente che aiutano tutti gli
altri servizi ecosistemici come il
fanalerogamo Marina quell'erba che
cresce sotto acqua dove i pesci
depositano le loro uova e così
garantiscono futuri racconti dei
Pescatori infine ci sono i servizi
ecosistemici di regolazione e sono le
cose che fa l'ambiente per rendere
vivibile la pianeta per noi nel caso
della laguna ci sono le balene le balene
sono quelle stese fangose
che con che sono periodicamente sommerse
non ne vediamo qua purtroppo che Sono
ricoperte di piante alofili assorbono e
sequestrano 40 volte più carbonio delle
foreste in questo modo aiutano a
controbilanciare avete sentito la parola
offset le emissioni di gas serra delle
attività produttive del gasolio che sta
usando questa barca in questo momento
e questo è il primo motivo per il quale
dico che Venezia salvando Venezia
Salviamo il mondo perché Venezia insieme
alle balene aiuta a mitigare i
cambiamenti climatici
c'è un altro importante servizio
ecosistemico della laguna che è un è un
fattore fisico dove ci sono le balene ci
sono più canali sinuosi meno profondi ci
sono le velve ci sono tutte queste
morfologie
morfologiche complesse che aiutano a
rallentare i correnti mariali e anche
dissipare l'energia delle onde
un effetto anche ad Attenuare i livelli
d'acqua nella città di Venezia non
ovviamente Durante gli eventi estremi
quando c'è così tanta tanto vento che è
un volume maggiore di acqua viene spinto
dentro la laguna e causa l'inondazione i
famosi Acque alte in città però le
balene avrebbero se ci fosse più bene
avremo la possibilità del loro aiuto
nella
Attenuare i livelli quotidiano
dell'acqua in città però oggi come oggi
abbiamo soltanto un sesto delle balene
che c'erano 500 anni fa
e questo effetto limitato delle parole
ci presenta una scelta molto difficile
o perché
sappiamo tutti che il livello medio del
mare sta aumentando
continuamente e ci ci toccherà dover
scegliere tra chiudere sempre più spesso
forse anche permanentemente le bocche di
porto con le barriere mobili o le
barriere fissi e avremo la laguna
soffocata oppure dobbiamo lasciare
entrare questa qua e Venezia non leggerà
fisicamente all'inondazione frequente e
non sarà neanche tanto abitabile
Ecco perché sono qui Io dico che bisogna
restituire alla laguna tutte le perline
che ci possono ospitare e dico che
abbiamo anche anni di ricerche e
esperienza per saperlo fare sappiamo le
tecniche non è come
pensare di poter rinnovare e andare ad
abitare su Marte sappiamo già Come fare
queste cose
sia nel caso delle delle chiusure
frequente delle bocche di Porto senza
barine sia nella nel caso che ho appena
descritto di una Laguna rigenerato le
attività portuali andranno
ridimensionati ma nel caso del
dipendenza sulle barriere avremo una
Laguna sempre più sterile nel caso della
laguna ripristinato avremo tutti quei
servizi ecosistemici sulla sul quale può
contare l'economia locale e questo vuol
dire riallineare
l'avere essenza e la vocazione di
Venezia basato sulla vita complessità e
dinamismi di questo ambiente unica
che abbiamo la storia di Venezia la
civiltà di Venezia è definito proprio da
questo saper convivere con la
complessità e l'ingegno degli abitanti a
saper direzionale i dinamismi naturali e
fisici a favore di una convivenza umana
questo funzionerà non per sempre
funzionerà fino a altri qualche decina
di centimetri di innalzamento del
livello del mare Ecco e questo è quando
dobbiamo pensare a tutto il resto del
mondo perché non possiamo solo pensare
alle scelte di Venezia perché già ora ci
sono delle conseguenze molto gravi dei
cambiamenti climatici Stamattina ero a
una riunione con la comunità del
Bangladesh che è il segmento più
numeroso della popolazione straniero a
Venezia c'era mio amico Gianni che mi ha
detto che suo figlio gli chiede papà
quando mi porti a vedere da dove vieni
in Bangladesh Ma c'è anche non ha più
una casa
non c'è più neanche tutto villaggio
perché è già stato lavato via
le persone del Bangladesh molti di loro
che sono qui a lavorare a vivere Sono
già classificati come il rifugiati
climatici
ci sto per concludere vorrei dire che
Vivendo e lavorando a Venezia subisco
questo ossessione quasi morbosa dei
media con tutti i disastri che
affliggono Venezia siamo diventati il
microcosmo dei peggiori problemi del
mondo
turismo di massa
decadenza ambientale inondazione e io
sento come il canarino nella miniera che
la gente Guarda noi per sapere cosa
accadrà altrove e noi abbiamo questo
enorme
responsabilità di risolvere questo
queste questioni però questa
responsabilità
viene insieme all'enorme privilegio di
vivere qui in questo gioiello squisito
dobbiamo
Succede ora riconciliare Venezia la
laguna mettere al centro dei processi
decisionale questo capitale naturale
della laguna E dimostrare che siamo
ancora in tempo a riequilibrare il
rapporto tra la natura e l'uomo